hey guys I am just McDonald it is the
second of April and you're tuned into
GameSpot news
first up the ps4 may be implementing a
player reputation system among other
features sony sent out a survey to ps4
users asking what they would like to see
in future console updates the survey
highlighted a number of areas that we
could see implemented at some stage
including an advanced matchmaking system
the option to change your username to
set your status as invisible and the
implementation of a player reputation
system based on a user rating system and
more check out the full list on site and
let me know what ps4 feature you think
Sony need to include next and now for
some relatively weird news Amazon seems
to be getting pretty heavily invested
into the game space the company have
announced amazon firetv a quad-core
video streaming device that will also
play games it has two gigabytes of RAM
and we'll run you 99 bucks and Amazon a
promising that it will have two times
the performance of competitors like
Apple TV if you want to play games on it
the Amazon fire game controller will
cost you 40 bucks games from EA Disney
and Sega are set to come to the device
as well as a version of minecraft no
oculus rift version of Minecraft but
there will be one on the Amazon console
fair enough the Box supports up to 7
remotes and game controllers connected
simultaneously as for in-game
microtransactions the console will
support amazon's payment services that
are already in place so you can click a
button and spend frivolously on
subscriptions or one-off purchases
without any extra effort
just like on Steam Amazon game studios
are all set to make games themselves to
starting off with a third-person shooter
called step 0 amazon of hired portal
designer Kim Swift and far cry 2 and
Splinter Cell designer Clint Hocking for
the studio which would suggests they're
pretty interested in making a big mock
on gaming last up Xbox co-creator Edie
fries has said that the Xbox one can win
the console war and here's how prizes
said they need better exclusive games
than ps4 they need to be more open to
indie developers they need to adopt
free-to-play gaming more aggressively
they need to
continue to move xboxlive forward as the
leading online service they need to show
people why they included the new Kinect
on every machine by demonstrating a
compelling use for it he also expressed
skepticism over whether vr would really
take off with the general public let me
know whether you reckon the Xbox one can
beat the ps4 in the console war in that
comment section down below or on my
Twitter where I'm at Jeff McDonald oh
you're very welcome to abstain or pledge
your allegiance to the PC everybody has
their favorites unless you're a Mac user
don't game on a Mac that is it for me
today if you're after some more news
head over to GameSpot and I do hope
we'll see you again tomorrow